oui alors
c'est difficile de faire campagne parce
qu'il ya une désinformation considérable
qui est véhiculée par nos adversaires
mais aujourd'hui par exemple avec le
premier ministre en a remis en
perspective ce qui a été annoncé à la
conférence de territoire et c'est
vraiment une nouvelle façon de
travailler les collectivités locales qui
consiste à construire des choses dans
les années à venir c'est un lieu de
dialogue et de décision il n'y aura plus
de décisions prises qui concernant les
collectivités locales sont qu'il y ait
une concertation qui se fait en amont il
ya des inquiétudes au niveau des élus
locaux aujourd'hui dû à la politique qui
a été menée ces dernières années et donc
à nous de convaincre des élus locaux que
la façon dont sera géré les relations
entre l'état les collectivités
territoriales entre gouvernement et les
élus locaux vont changer et que la
méthode mc ren c'est autre chose que ce
qui a été appliqué ces dernières années
et concernant l'accueil de quelqu'un
comme moi qui viens de la société civile
je trouve que l'accueil est plutôt
intéressé positif parce que nous on est
à l'écart des clivages politiques locaux
c'est très important ça veut dire que
nous on sera capable vraiment de
travailler avec les collectivités avec
des élus locaux de toutes sensibilités
politiques pour essayer justement de
porter au niveau national des
propositions et des messages qui portons
des câlins quand
sue s'est développée sur le plan local